la posesión ford es loco y chiflado
estas fueron las palabras que usaron los
asesores de donald trump para describir
su campaña de presión de último minuto
contra mike pence mientras el entonces
presidente de eeuu intentaba convencer a
su vicepresidente de que anulara su
derrota en las elecciones de 2020 el
jueves la comisión que investiga los
disturbios del 6 de enero social hizo
una llamada telefónica que trump y top
ens durante la mañana de la insurrección
de conversations pues la conversación
fue bastante acalorada era un tono
diferente al que le había escuchado
antes con el vicepresidente la escases
de autor forma fotografías inéditas
muestran a pence resguardándose mientras
la turba pero trump irrumpía en el
capitolio el testimonio mostró que el
vicepresidente se acercó a menos de 40
pies los alborotadores algunos de los
cuales estaban cantando para que pence
fuera ahorcado según el panel la presión
de trump sobre pence para anular la
votación condujo directamente a la
insurrección incluyendo los comentarios
improvisados que hizo en un mitin horas
mike pence va a tener que salir adelante
por nosotros y si no lo hace será un día
triste para nosotros
el comité también dijo que el abogado de
trump john eastman fue la artífice del
complot para re venir los resultados de
las elecciones a pesar de saber que era
ilegal
johnny admitió alguna vez que usted sepa
tirante el presidente que su propuesta
violaría la ley de recuento electoral
creo que lo hizo el día 4 el comité
tiene previsto celebrar tres audiencias
más y se espera que entregue un informe
final sobre sus conclusiones a finales
de año